What's, what's the difference between Ivermectin and Fendizol?
I've been using Fendizol, I want to try Ivermectin also.
So these are medications.
So the Fendizol that is typically used, so I can't make a lot of comments on this.
I think this person is talking about cancer.
So there is a Fendizol treatment for cancer.
There is an Ivermectin treatment for cancer.
There's documented evidence that these things can be beneficial for somebody with cancer.
So I can't make a lot of comments on those, that because this is a medication.
But I can encourage you to give them a try.
These are, you know, medications that have been out for decades and decades and decades
without giving, you know, very few side effects.
So it's not something that would endanger anybody to take this thing.
Typically, that recommended dosage for cancer with Fendizol is the same dosage you can give
a 10 pound dog.
Now, Fendizol is typically a dog, dewormer, cat dewormer.
So it's an anti-paracidic medication, and it could be purchased over the counter.
And the dosage that's typically recommended is what's given for a small dog.
So there's no danger in, or harm in taking it.
It's not necessarily a high enough dose that's going to take care of all the person's parasites
if they have parasites.
They may want to use some natural things, too.
But if they're taking it for cancer, you're not taking it for parasites.
You're taking it for cancer because it affects the cancer cell.
Ivermectin as well, it could be used that way, too.